une réponse alexandre benhadda ce qu'il
a dit ce matin en disant que les
parlementaires étaient de petite
personne en disant que la commission
d'enquêté allait à l'encontre de la
démocratie
et est ce que vous confirmez la date
c'est à dire que la semaine prochaine il
sera auditionné le 19 ans avait deux
questions sur la première écoute et ça
ne mérite pas de commentaire il faut que
monsieur benalla prennent conscience de
l'importance de la représentation
nationale dans notre pays
et puis à cordes à celle ci le respect
minimal qu'on est en droit d'attendre de
tous nos concitoyens dans l'exercice de
notre mission qui consiste à faire en
sorte que l'état fonctionne bien et
améliorer le fonctionnement quand il ya
des dysfonctionnements
quant à l'audition de monsieur benalla
comme ça a été dit et redit
elle devrait normalement avoir lieu le
19 septembre au matin